it is amazing it's  it's like unbelievable  i'm i'm so happy thank you  i am flattered i love my job i'm proud  to represent treasure island and i  couldn't be biased couldn't be  with better people at work  so what do you think guys can you handle  any more attention  oh i don't think so man  yeah we can do it  for a long time  you know it's really wonderful you know  to be  honored like this  you never would have thought  so what's the what's the next 50 years  going to be like  i don't know  who thanks  oh my gosh it's been so incredible it's  so wonderful to be recognized by  lvcva and my peers it really means a lot  to me especially during this pandemic  time where everyone's having a hard time